major airlines say beginning tomorrow
thousands of flights could be canceled
if a planned rollout of 5g cell service
isn't halted now there are concerns that
it interferes with a plane's technology
specifically the system that helps
pilots land in bad weather our
washington correspondent trevor shirley
is in d.c with the latest in this back
and forth
well as of this afternoon both a t and t
and verizon say they'll temporarily
delay their rollouts of some 5g towers
around certain airports two weeks ago
the airline industry struck a deal with
at t and verizon to delay the rollout by
two weeks that period ends tomorrow
right now over the next 24 less than 24
hours what we're focused on is
trying to come to a solution in a letter
to president biden airline ceos say they
want the administration to ban the use
of 5g within 2 miles of airports until
more safety data is collected 5g uses a
bandwidth that can interfere with the
plane's altimeter which tells a pilot
how close to the ground they are it's
important to use during landings
especially in bad weather at t and
verizon both say their 5g service will
not interfere with the plane's
instruments at t also criticized the faa
today for not deploying this technology
safely which at t says 40 other
countries have already done critics also
say airlines knew for years this change
was coming and failed to adapt their own
technology the administration says talks
are ongoing about a solution we believe
that with continued cooperation we can
chart a path forward but certainly
minimizing flight disruptions ensuring
safety and travel is a top priority
and the airlines say if no changes
happen more than a thousand flights a
day could be canceled or delayed report